queremos evaluar la integral definida
desde menos 1 hasta menos 2 de m16
x cúbica todo esto entre x cúbica de x
ahora tal vez en un principio esto
podría parecer un poco abrumador
tengo esa expresión racional de aquí
tengo a x en el numerador y axn el
denominador y entonces cómo resuelvo
esto solo tenemos que hacer un poco de
manipulación algebraica y esto nos va a
parecer mucho más atractivo esto es lo
mismo que la integral definida de menos
1 - 2 de 16 entre x cúbica - x cúbica
entre x cúbica y todo esto de x
ya que va a ser esto igual bueno pues
esto va a ser igual a la integral
definida de menos 12 de y podré escribir
este término de aquí el primero como 16
x a la menos 3 y el segundo como bueno
observa que tengo menos x kubica
entre x kubica lo cual es menos uno
entonces me quedarían menos 1 de x y
entonces a que va a ser igual esto bueno
pues vamos a sacar la anti derivada de
cada una de estas partes y luego vamos a
evaluar en los diferentes límites de
integración entonces veamos la anti
derivada de 16 x a la menos 3 bueno sólo
hay que usar la regla de las potencias
para derivadas al revés podrían ver esto
como la regla de las potencias de
integración o también es lo mismo que la
regla de las potencias sacan delante
derivada donde lo que harán será primero
aumentar nuestro exponente en 1 así que
vamos a ir en este caso de menos 3 al
menos 2 y luego hay que dividir por esa
misma cantidad menos 2 entonces esto va
a ser igual a 16 entre menos 2
x la menos 2 todo lo que dice fomentar
el exponente y lo dividía entre esa
misma cantidad pero ahora observan tengo
16 entre menos 2 es lo mismo que menos 8
entonces voy a quitar esto y voy a poner
menos 8x a la menos 2 y ahora tengo el
anti derivada de menos 1 bueno eso es
simplemente menos x y en realidad ya
deberían de saber eso si está con la
derivada de menos x me da menos 1 o si
ven esto como - x elevado la potencia
cero entonces aplicamos lo mismo que
hice acá arriba me quedaría si sumamos
uno al exponente
me quedan menos x elevado a la primera
potencia y luego dividido esto entre 1
así que puedes ver fácilmente que
llegamos a menos x y ahora queremos
evaluar esto este resultado en nuestros
límites de integración y después sacar
la diferencia entonces vamos a evaluar
esto primero al menos dos y luego
restarle esto evaluado en menos uno si
lo evaluamos primero en menos dos que me
queda bueno esto de aquí va a ser igual
- 8 que multiplican a menos 2 elevado a
la menos 2
y a esto le vamos a quitar menos -2 ya
todo esto le vamos a restar la
evaluación en menos 1 lo cual va a ser
menos 8 x menos 1 elevado a la menos dos
menos menos 1 muy bien y entonces aquí
va a ser igual todo esto bueno qué te
parece si primero vemos cuánto es menos
2 elevado a la menos 2 y menos 2 elevado
al menos 2 va a ser igual a bueno 1
entre menos 2 al cuadrado que es lo
mismo que un cuarto entonces todo esto
es igual a un cuarto positivo pero si lo
multiplicamos por menos 8 me va a quedar
que todo esto es menos 2 y luego tenemos
menos menos dos entonces todo esto
simplemente es menos 2 más 2 lo cual va
a ser igual a cero así que toda esta
parte que tenemos el morado es
simplemente cero y ahora vamos a ver qué
sucede con la parte anaranjada cuando
evaluamos a x x menos 1 veamos
tengo menos 1 elevado a la menos 2
bueno eso es lo mismo que uno entre
menos 1 al cuadrado lo cual es
simplemente 1 y entonces vamos a tener
menos 8 menos menos uno lo cual es menos
8 más 1 y todo esto es igual a menos 7
entonces todo esto se evalúa menos 7
pero recuerda estamos restando menos 7
así que aquí hay un signo negativo y
ahora es momento de ponerle un redoble
de tambor porque ya puedo decir que todo
esto es igual a 7 positivo bueno no es
necesario escribir si lo positivo en
frente sólo lo hago para enfatizar que
todo esto va a ser igual a 7 positivo